Have any thoughts at all once you'd finally retired?
Like maybe one more.
Did you ever have any thoughts like that?
Well,
you know,
um,
I told people like I'll take,
I'll take my pajamas off for a hundred mil.
Mm.
So
she serious come with the baby,
show me the paper.
But who would have to be against a j maybe no meals,
no snacking and enticing.
But when you had beat and Tyson,
you'd beat Tyson.
That was kind of at the end of his stage two.
Right.
It wasn't the same guy.
Like I've,
I,
I looked at Tyson's history,
you know,
it's coming from the same history that I'm coming from,
and he spent some time in incarceration while he was incarceration.
I'm still out there fighting and training hard.
He didn't have that in there.
So when,
when he came out,
it's like,
you know,
he's trained again.
He's doing what he,
what he knows not what he loves,
what he knows.
That's what's going to make him some money that's going to put food on this
table.
So it's like I look at old time fighters and say what made them stay in boxing
so long?
That's the only thing they knew,
right.
They didn't,
they,
they're not going to be no singer or dance or whatever.
They only know boxing and this is where they get their money from.
So they,
that's what,
that's what forces and back into the ring,
especially especially olden days.
And that's why they were called prize fighters because they wouldn't make enough
money to,
to make a living unless you were like a huge,
I get Jack Dempsey or ray robins,
ray Robinson fought way,
way,
way past its prime.
It again cause they were making good money at the time but not the money that
they would have been making if it was today.
Well there was no,
I mean you had to go see it live,
you know like how much yeah,
we'll get paid for the radio.
Who Was it?
Was that fight on the radio?
Was it Jack Dempsey?
Gene tiny.
That was the first million dollar gate.
I think.
So one of those,
Ray Arcel did that fight I think.
And that create what does $1 million back then?
It sets a lot of money back then it was in the 1920s,
right?
Yeah.
Just say Jack Gene Tunney Jack Gene.
This gene Tunney.
Yeah.
Um,
when,
when Tyson was in jail,
he must've been doing something cause he came out jacked.
Like he looked good.
Like he came out looking different than he ever looked like six pack fully built
when he fought Peter McNeely.
Terrifying.
But like physically he looked really good too.
Like you look better than he ever looked.
More ripped than ever.
So when he went in he was a little chubby.
Yeah.
You know,
what is it doing there?
Yes.
Nothing else.
That's weights.
Fuck dudes.
That's why here,
you know
how many dudes before it's enough.
That's how much time you're in there for it.
Yeah.
That was him when he came out.
He was shredded it and it was so much more muscular.
So he's probably,
he probably couldn't do any sparring.
I doubt they had a heavy bag,
but they probably had a weight room,
you know,
but you can fight,
you can fight in prison.
And he was like 28,
29 there.
It depends on what prison,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I'm saying even fight,
just fight.
Fight people.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what,
somebody would have tried to start some shit with,
oh I'm sure.
I'm sure we're not on guard even,
you know.
Yeah,
I bet.
I bet he had to listen to a lot of shitty things regarding,
it's funny when I seen him be arrested,
taken from the courtroom and they got,
they must've got the biggest guy they could ever get to go put handcuffs on him
or something like that.
Um,
anyway,
situation that.
Yeah.
I hope a lot of people stay away from,
yeah.
When he went away did you feel like,
dammit,
like I'm going to miss out on that fight that I want it.
Yes.
Straight away.
And he's like,
oh no,
I'm going to have to wait and delay my retirement.
Oh,
so you were waiting,
you were considering retirement even before he was incarcerated?
Yeah.
Wow.
Interesting.
Cause then you were chasing the bull fight.
Both fights,
chicken bowl,
you know,
you figured that,
um,
chicken bowl.
So she couldn't call them ridiculous bro.
Ridiculous book.
She can go try to pick a fight with me the other day did,
didn't really do the other day.
He did.
Yeah.
Where,
um,
other fights,
like in la where they called all the great ones on Gerry Cooney,
me,
uh,
foreman Spinks was there.
And what was he doing?
He wanted to stand beside me and take a picture.
I'm like,
dude,
you can't stand beside me.
Costs down where I want.
Understand.
I'm like,
dude,
you're going to have to move.
So Gerry Cooney kind of helped us out there while I'm saved him
because he.